last thing and I know you guys have
explained the multiverse a zillion times
this part I still can't wrap my mind or
a half when cap goes back yeah where is
the cap in that world like hey so when
he goes back to the early days is there
still another Captain America in that
world yes so the the way that it would
work right is that when Captain America
goes back the Russo brothers have
finally explained what happened to
Captain America when he went back in
time and lived his life with Peggy
Carter did he create a branched new
timeline were there two Captain
America's in that same timeline all
these questions are finally answered at
the end of Avengers in game we watched
Captain America go back in time to
return all of the Infinity stones and
then we watched him stay back in time to
live his life out with Peggy Carter
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this is probably one of the most
fulfilling scenes that we've seen in the
MCU however it is very confusing
after avengers endgame people started to
wonder well when Captain America went
back in time did he create this new
reality one in which he is married to
Peggy Carter or did he somehow stay in
the same reality and was Peggy's husband
all along this got even more confusing
when the writers came out and said that
they viewed Captain America as Peggy's
husband the whole entire time and that
he did not create a branched reality
when he went back in time they said that
to them
the writers even in Captain America the
Winter Soldier captain was always Peggy
Carter's husband and when she refers to
her husband she is actually referring to
Steve but then the directors came out
and said that this wasn't true they said
that he was not in the same reality that
he came from but he actually created a
different reality it's been pretty
confusing and quite the debate but the
directors have finally spoken up again
clarifying it once and for all what
exactly happened to Captain America at
the end of Avengers endgame quickly
before we dive into it if you would like
a chance to win a Captain America shield
an Iron Man helmet and Infinity Gauntlet
or another Marvel Legends item be sure
to subscribe to my channel to enter my
giveaway I'll be picking three winners
at four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers so in a recent interview
with Fox v DC the Russo brothers have
finally answered this question once and
for all there's still another Captain
America in that world yes so the the
way that it wouldn't work right is that
when Captain America goes back he would
create a branch reality right okay now
he would exist in that branch reality
with a second Captain America who was
frozen and ice so the other cat still
exists in that world so no they do not
know that other cap
well he's that other cap is frozen in
ice and Peggy understood that he was
dead at that point in the storytelling
cuz calf went back to a point in time
where nobody knew he still was alive
frozen and ice no it's also a story for
another time as of course you created a
branch reality he would then have to use
a Pym particle to come back or hand that
shield off yeah that's unbelievable so
as you just saw the Russo brothers have
officially stated that Captain America
did create a branched reality when he
went back in time and then at the end of
the movie he used a Pym particle to
travel back to the present time to give
Sam his shield and he also did confirmed
that there were two Captain America's in
that timeline one was just frozen in ice
remember that Captain America was in the
ice for 70 years and although he has the
Super Soldier Serum that's really what
preserved him for that long
him being frozen so when the present-day
Captain America who people speculate is
about 39 years old goes back in time he
gets to live a full life with Peggy
Carter while the other Captain America
is still in the ice so for those of you
who were wondering what Captain America
did during this timeline it sounds like
he didn't really do anything but marry
the love of his life Peggy Carter
because when they would find Captain
America and the ice team normal events
that really played out in his timeline
would pretty much play out in this
timeline as well and this could mean
that Peggy Carter's kids were Captain
America's kids but the Russo brothers
did officially say that this did create
a branched timeline so the debate is
finally settled once and for all so let
me know what you think about this is
this a satisfying answer to you do you
like what the Russo brothers said him
having created a branched reality or do
you like what the producer said and do
you ever think that we'll see a film or
a TV series showing what happened to
Captain America in that other timeline
be sure to let me know in the comments
and also comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my
so you can enter my giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof